board members
a 1997 graduate carey has been a member
of the alumni executive board for six
years she has served as secretary vice
president and now president
on behalf of the alumni board and the
entire alumni association i wish to
thank her for her loyal service
she's done an outstanding job leading
the alumni association board during a
difficult time she's been the right
person in the right seat to keep our
volunteers engaged
carrie and her husband richard reside in
glenview illinois they have four grown
children and three grandchildren
please join me in welcoming carrie
thank you colleen
it is my privilege to introduce dr larry
arn who is in his 21st year as president
of hillsdale
during this time dr arne has overseen
the unprecedented growth of the college
both in the physical plant and in the
development of its academic and outreach
efforts
the college has emerged in the last 21
years
as truly a nationally ranked
undergraduate institution
with over 70 percent of students now
enrolling from out of state
and a near 20 percent rate of admission
under dr
arne's leadership millions are now able
to access hillsdale's classical liberal
arts education
through the development of the college's
vast outreach efforts
these include the van andel graduate
school of statesmanship
van andel graduate school of government
hillsdale in d.c
the churchill project the halter
shooting sports center the gordon
biology station
30 online courses
the establishment of hillsdale k-12 with
40 affiliated schools across the country
the new blake center for faith and
freedom and the growth of the college's
flagship
publication in primus to more than 6
million readers
dr arn has published widely on the
issues of public policy and political
theory
is past president of the philadelphia
society
is a member of the board of trustees for
the heritage foundation and the board of
directors of the henry salvatore center
of claremont mckenna college
the intercollegiate studies institute
and the claremont institute
in 2015 dr arne received the bradley
prize from the lindy and harry bradley
foundation
recently he was appointed to former
president trump's
1776 commission
which was established to restore an
american education an understanding
of the history and the principles of the
founding of the united states
published widely in newspapers and
magazines and periodicals on issues of
public policy history and political
theory
dr arn is the author of three books
liberty and learning
the evolution of the american education
the founders key the divine and natural
connection between the declaration and
the constitution and what we risk by
losing it
and churchill's trial winston churchill
and the salvation of free government
dr arn travels tirelessly to educate
others and raise support for the college
yet he still finds time to frequent the
cafeteria and have lunch with students
as well as teach classes in politics and
history
he and his wife penny have four children
henry katie alice and tony and recently
welcomed their first grandchild
charlotte
please join me in welcoming our
dedicated and accomplished president dr
larry yarn
[Applause]
neil cole are you not a sigma chi
are you a sigma chi
and he's skipping the 40th birthday
party
well done
uh welcome back thank you colleen and
thank you carrie
uh
it's a joy to see you all
uh
it's a
a measure of the continuity of the
college to have you all
the college is continuous
it's
looks like we're going to get to have
college again next year
um
i uh recognized
two new is built bill nolan's not here
he's with the sigma cause are you here
bill nolan no
there's three new trustees and two are
here
and i'm going to ask them to stand up
bill
forget bill nolan he didn't come
donna ecten and david huff are here and
would they stand up please
uh and i recognize the recipients
two of them i know well
two of them are too old
i'll prove how well i know them
and then i'll
praise the other two
jared valdeira is the best football
player we ever had
the second best is john cevini who's
here tonight
whom we learned today is the first
academic all-american
in hillsdale college history and nobody
mentioned at the board meeting because
somebody brought that up that he was
both kinds of all-american
and i don't know if jared was both kinds
or not
uh
jared was like john
an offensive lineman
and john and i revel in the fact that on
the wonderlic iq test
the offensive linemen are the smartest
and i was an offensive lineman
i just wasn't very good at being a
lineman
and there are two games that mark in my
memory the excellence of the man
and one was we beat grand valley state
won the conference that year
and we beat him with a long drive where
we ran over and over on the left side
and because i was a lineman and because
i love football in the frustrated way
somebody loves it who was never all that
good at it
i watched him block
the left side of the line
of grand valley state
it was just awesome and they they have
you know very fancy scheme
and they the linebackers are fast and
they move around
and the linemen stop things upright and
then they dart in well he just blocked
the guy in front of him
and the linebacker too
and he did it over and over it was
obvious
right
and then we played in the playoffs the
first game mankato state and when the
offensive line came out they didn't look
like
oxen
they looked like mineral deposits
they were enormous
and the way they did it
you can see by the way that uh my method
my approach to football was to try to
think it through
and so i noticed things right and they
they would all stunt in a similar
direction
and they'd try to get momentum and
they'd try to run over us
and i said to jared after the game
how did you stop them and you know that
was his cue to say well you know we
worked really hard and all that stuff
and
we trained you know or something that's
what they say in all the interviews no
he didn't he said you take this foot and
you move it right over here and then you
go like this
he was giving me instruction how to play
in the offensive line
and the last thing about him is when he
joined the oakland raiders
there were articles about him and the
articles always mentioned something
about what a nice and well-spoken young
man he was
and this is the nfl they're not used to
that
and the raiders least of all
so i'm proud of him
uh
joy pulley pullman is a journalist and i
had her husband in class i never had her
she was too good for me
and she's she's won national fame and
she's a very fierce woman
and
it's just you know she's
insightful and she's tough and she loves
her family and the family
and she loves good education and and her
education
and she writes about those things with
real conviction
so i'm proud of her
come on
oh ron gladnick
where's gladnig
yeah yeah so
i met him through john cervini
and they're just alike
except i think gladneque may be richer
and cerini smarter
and what are you doing now
you're a little
yeah you sold your company and got a lot
of dough
and i'm he's just agreed to give a very
large gift to hillsdale college or has
he
i did that on behalf of
john
[Laughter]
congratulations to you and he was a big
jock and he looks like it too
he was really great
and uh okay come on where else am i
uh
our last
recipient i don't know him and where is
he
right here and he's a
very successful man
and i looked up some stuff about him and
uh
the people who work with him for him
like him a lot
and he's going to give a great talk
tonight
i look forward to that
and because of that i'll shut up pretty
quick
i just want to tell you hillsdale
college
has never been more threatened and never
been more successful
things are underway in washington d.c
that will
shift yet more from the private to the
public sector
they're very interested in controlling
charitable giving these days
and
surely that will not be
allowed to happen but if it is surely we
will find a way to survive that
but in the face of all that
i mean it's just
marvelous to us
what's happened here
i'm not going to state numbers but
you know
giving to hillsdale college has risen
every year for 21 years in a row
but there have been two big jumps
both in the middle of a crisis
and after the first crisis
it didn't fall off after that
so i'm hoping because this jump is
bigger and i'm hoping it doesn't fall
off after this jump
and that makes amazing things possible
it may it basically means that we can
pay for
the excellence around here
uh we hired 21 new faculty members this
year
we set out to get 16
and the applications were so great that
we would hire two but we're only meant
to hire one and i'm the one who got
carried away
people from the ivy league are begging
to come to work here
and why because
the kids are smart and they're
respectful
and they do the work
and everybody's nice to each other
in other words it acts like a college
and you know if somebody's not nice to
somebody then we'll speak to them but
that hardly ever happens
uh
you know the
the entering scores of the freshman
class which is 75 students over budget
that's twenty percent over budget
are the highest ever and one point
behind below the averages of harvard
and we could
match harvard if we wanted to if we just
adopted the practice of admitting
everybody who makes a perfect score on
the entrance exams
but we always turned down six or eight
or ten of those ten in last year
and we do it because they come in here
acting like they're god's gift to man
and we remind them that they're only 17
or 18 years old
my favorite question is what can you
possibly know
[Laughter]
and you know that's
we really pat ourselves on the back
about things like that
the college is successful
and the college is reaching everywhere
that's an element of its success
we have 20 charter schools
we have 11 in process
we're getting ready to try to form
50 in tennessee at the request of the
governor of tennessee
and and to pursue that idea i mean he
just he called me up and said you're
coming to nashville and i said i am and
he said come see me so i go
he gives us lunch and he said
he said a prayer he had his whole senior
management there including one kid named
gurkey who's a hillsdale kid
calvin be quiet
he said
after he said his prayer he said
we need hillsdale college in tennessee
and i said governor hillsdale college is
very heavy and hard to move
and he said
i know but he said you're starting these
education centers
we have one in d.c it's a graduate
school and thriving and we have one in
summers connecticut that has a replica
of monticello on it
and we know a million people on our
mailing list who live within a 90-minute
drive of that place
so we're going to have stuff there
and we're going to teach
and there's about to be one i do believe
in placer county california north of
sacramento
and this morning's news is that there
might be another one outside fresno on
the king river where it comes out of the
sierras very beautiful place
and that's all stupid and difficult
but those things bring a lot of money
with them
and so you know i'm i'm not trained in
being a businessman but i know enough
about it to know you don't take your
existing revenues and spread them over a
larger expense base
so we don't have to
why are those things happening
oh online courses
half a million people knew signed up for
those last year
and they're three million total now
and the
percentage that finish the courses and
take the exams is rising all the time
i get stopped in airports now
saying
i'm taking your course
and then they you know and they're like
sometimes they're 70 sometimes they're
30 sometimes they're 15.
and they act like students you know they
often have a question
they make a comment
and if you ask them if they're taking
their exams and how they're doing they
turn into freshmen
they look at their feet and look
embarrassed
these are treasures
and they're happening here
and it's unprecedented i don't think
that's an exaggeration
it's important for us to remember who
owns the college
uh
have you ever asked yourself that
question
who owns the college
uh general motors belongs to its
stockholders
right
hillsdale college is 177 years old
and has been under the same ownership
all that time
the owners are named in the beautiful
founding document of the college as they
are by the way
in the founding of every charity in the
nation
the college belongs to its beneficiaries
the people it names in its founding
document is charter that it intends to
benefit
who are those people
every
student but every student down through
time
that means we pray
millions unborn
every employee of course
we serve it and we get paid
but
we owe it too
that means all the citizens
whose freedom is to be reinforced by the
teachings of the college this is all
said in the founding document
every christian
who wants to practice an intelligent
form of piety
the college belongs to all of them
the reason the board of trustees is
important is because
their charge is to act for all of them
to keep them in mind every day we who
run the college we try to keep them in
mind too but
some days it's an emergency
there's 1600 kids here god knows what
they're going to do on any given day
although they behave better than you did
when you were here
this this bunch i feel really old this
bunch sitting right here i remember them
distinctly when they were students and
i'm astonished that they're still alive
they did they did they got married and
like
jodie lent
he was a boy given to self-reflection
he's a classics major he's actually very
intelligent although you can't tell by
looking at him
and he would come in my office often and
he would agonize about whether he's
doing the right thing or not he's a
classics major the specific purpose of
the major is to answer the question what
is the right thing
ridiculous
the articles of associations say that we
are going to
perpetuate
the blessings of civil and religious
liberty and intelligent piety
the claim is that those are eternal
goods and they are worthy of
eternal preservation
who's responsible to do that
come to find out
above all it is we
who have enjoyed its benefits
when you were students here you paid a
small fraction
of the cost of it
but that's not the cost
the cost is work
and thinking and conversation
and concentration
and alertness and a commitment if you
study the things we teach here to keep
thinking about those for the rest of
your life
so what
so you can live them
and teach them to others
uh this year
we just got our audit today yesterday
today
and uh
this year the students have paid for six
percent of the cost of hillsdale college
and that's right actually as long
as they remember
to be grateful for that
because the funds have been supplied
by literally millions of people
who get nothing for it except a share
in the pursuit of the love that we
represent and share here actively
hillsdale college is a massive community
it encompasses people by the tens of
millions
in every corner of the land
and millions of people
pin their hopes on it
we are the ones who have received its
benefits the most richly
we are the ones
who owe
those who haven't who never get to
i remember
one year there were sterns around
because
a cca audience now from outside
is like six or eight hundred people
and you know the people who come are
very annoying
they asked dumb questions and you know
and they uh
and uh we built this auditorium right so
they can in this so they have a place to
sit
and uh
very nice young woman
an r.a when i talk every term at the
beginning of every term to the ras and
that's always an inspiring experience
because they're the best
and this young woman said to me two
years ago she said
and i was about to leave i said anything
else
and i had put my
coat picked up my coat in my briefcase
and she said
why do we have to have these visitors
here
isn't this for
us and the record shows that i put my
coat down in my briefcase
and i answered that question for 30
minutes
and i explained to her about the
obligations she has
because she could never pay for this
you see
and she has to eat and has to live and
has to have shelter and all that stuff
and everybody around here has got to be
paid
and i said do you see the obligation you
have
they come here
to a little bit of what you get to
immerse yourself in
don't you owe them
you should teach them
and i know they ask dumb questions
you know because they're not like us
they're not in the military
you know they're civilians
and
and we're marines here right we train
we get ready
we concentrate for years
i say
when they ask a dumb question
go introduce yourself
and teach them something
help them understand
you want to live in a free country that
understand
standing needs to grow and it needs to
grow fast
and it all starts right here
thank you for coming back
[Applause]
thank you dr
arne the hillsdale college alumni
association was organized at the close
of the civil war think about that alumni
back then
saw the importance of supporting the
college
upon its founding the association
adopted its own mission statement which
called upon its members
to keep the alumni fully informed
help maintain the standards of the
college
aid in the enrollment of new students
and encourage all alumni to tangibly
support the college by developing
programs to ensure its continued growth
that is our same mission today
today our 30-member alumni association
board works hard on behalf of the more
than fifteen thousand alumni association
members to honor and uphold this one
hundred and fifty two-year-old
commitment
for seventy years it's been a tradition
to hold this banquet to recognize the
achievement and service of some of our
most outstanding graduates and that's
what brings us here tonight
but before we transition to honoring
those awardees i'd like to take a few
minutes to acknowledge and thank members
of the alumni association board who are
finishing their final year of service
these members all have served two
four-year terms and have dedicated their
time and expertise to the college in a
variety of ways
we're very grateful for their service
and for their love and enthusiasm for
our alma mater
the following members were not able to
join us this evening tyler horning scott
keenan mark donovan and andrew fink but
i would like to call those two members
up here um
marianne rotoli class of 1995
and richard rocket casera a class of
1976.
i'd like you to come up so i can present
you with a gift on behalf of the college
and formally thank you for your service
to hillsdale college
[Applause]
so on behalf of on behalf of hillsdale
college we want to thank you for your
service and by presenting you with this
beautiful watercolor of central hall
[Applause]
well it looks like i may have
moved forward a little bit faster than i
meant to
um
let's begin
this evening we'll be recognizing four
outstanding alumni their achievements
are detailed in your table programs and
i encourage you to read those but if you
have not already done so i'll make an
introduction of each honoree that will
be followed by a short video
these videos have been added in the last
few years and i just think they're just
fabulous ways of presenting our honorees
to all of you
after that dr aaron and i will present
each recipient with an award and each
recipient will be asked to make remarks
if they wish
and jared i know you already volunteered
to make those remarks so you're going to
be kicking this off he wanted to know
right away
what number he was and i said well we're
starting with you so you set that tone
our first honoree is jarrod valdir class
of 2009.
jared is a retired oh his t his table
would like to applaud at the beginning
thank you okay
again he's setting the tone
uh jared is a retired nfl offensive
tackle and was a four-year starter at
hillsdale he was named first team all
glee
gliac in 2008 and 2009 and first team
all-american by the american football
coaches association in 2009 he helped
hillsdale qualify for the ncaa division
2 playoffs for the first time in 2009
and advanced to the second round
in his 46 hillsdale starts at left
tackle he never allowed a sack
and the chargers had their two highest
scoring seasons up until that point in
history
2007-2009
jared was a third round draft pick in
the oakland raiders 69th overall in the
2010 nfl draft
in march 2014 he signed a five-year
contract with the arizona cardinals
in 2015 the cardinals finished with a
13-3 record and had the highest scoring
offense in the nfl
jared was named team mvp by his
teammates after that 2014 season
he left the cardinals in 2017 and went
on to play with the denver broncos the
new england patriots the green bay
packers and the indianapolis colts
before retiring from the nfl in 2021
jared is a native of grand rapids
majored in biology and belonged to the
delta sigma phi fraternity
he now serves as director of health and
wellness for strategies wealth advisors
and is an active craft beer brewer
he says thank you for that morgan uh his
wife morgan also a 2012 graduate are
active volunteers and generous
supporters of the college in many ways
they have two children eva and edwin
and please give your attention to the
screen to meet our distinguished alumni
honoree jared voldeer
[Music]
as an offensive lineman you're always
working behind the scenes you know how
to you know handle success
humbly um because when you have that
success your your name's not going to be
printed in a newspaper article maybe you
know you get a shout out you know the
o-line as a unit would get a shout out
from the running backs quarterbacks
coaches whatever but we knew to never
get too high after success never get too
low
you know if there's any kind of failure
that it just really took you know five
guys to you know grind day in day out
and look to keep getting better and
build as a unit
my name is jared veldir i grew up in
grand rapids michigan uh born and raised
football even professional football you
know i didn't really see that in my
future much like maybe college football
but i like basketball a lot more coach
otterbein came and watched one of my
basketball games
and then offered me a scholarship to
play football after and
i accepted pretty quick because i was
already familiar with the school my
brother went there played basketball
there i i could see
you know the value in being at an
institution like that for four plus
years
the nfl thought first popped in my head
after my
freshman year i was able to put on some
good size strength and speed and a
couple guys just started joking about it
like hey you're just as big as these
guys that are you know getting drafted
or you know in the combine and that are
playing in the nfl and it never seemed
too stressful and it just seemed kind of
you know a lighthearted fun goal to go
about you we finished our our football
season
in november and then immediately i
signed with an agent and that whole
process started to go um you know heard
my name called with the 69th pick in the
in the in the draft
which was the third
round just uh kind of a whirlwind you
know just instant like elation and then
just craziness
looking back at the transition between
division two and the nfl getting moved
from left tackle to right tackle
probably sticks out as the biggest
challenge because i played left tackle
my whole time at hillsdale and played
left tackle for the first seven years of
the nfl career and when i took those
initial right tackle sets and it just
felt so awkward you know my body was
just so programmed to move
from from a left-handed stance i mean i
wanted to
basically quit in training camp because
i felt like i was just so worthless and
that i was you know no longer that one
of those five guys that was accountable
to one another and that i couldn't do my
job and i didn't want to do that to the
group and the team and it's never fun
when you have to learn through playing
in front of you know 60 000 plus people
but uh
again just kind of keep your head down
and try to get better and correct things
and fix it as you go and that's what i
did and figured it out and so it's nice
being able to
take some of those lessons and now
you know try to apply them outside of
football you know trying to to raise a
young family and you know now being back
in west michigan and you know just
life-changing sometimes you feel like
you can maybe lose your footing but with
what i've you know learned i'm able to
kind of stay grounded if that makes
sense
you know something that everyone who's
gone to hillsdale's heard you know a
million times it's the people um
and i think it really applies because uh
you know without that great group of
people there i don't know how many
people would stick around and survive
and thrive and have a really you know
good academic career athletic career
whatever it is there it's it's a tough
place so it was a losing record my
freshman year and then uh it seemed like
each year i think it was each year we we
had gotten better improved uh and then
my senior year we made it to the
division two playoffs for the first time
in school history and coach otterbein
was a great coach
you know i i really you know tipped my
hat to him being able to work with uh 18
to you know 22 year old
kids and turn them into men and i think
that was always his number one goal and
when you're going through you know the
same kind of challenges the same
difficulties the same you know stages of
life and uh you know you're doing it
together you know non-stop you need to
force some really special relationships
and uh is definitely able to do that at
hillsdale not trying to put words in
your mouth coach otter but
you know if you can mold those those
good men those good human beings that
the winds would follow that because that
was the most important piece without
that then the winds wouldn't happen
[Applause]
jared will you please come forward
and dr erin
i'll have you stand here and dr aaron
will be next to you
jared on behalf of the alumni
association of hillsdale college it's my
great honor to present you with the
[Applause]
distinguished alumni achievement award
for professional athletics
congratulations
just right now i doubt the truth of the
statement the bigger they are the harder
they fall
i don't think any tall people said that
no where's where's mr lantis
what happened to the revision on the i
am no longer the strategies wealth
advisors uh health and wellness
consultant i have now moved on to bigger
and better things i am the i'm the
school lunch lady
uh for saint paul the apostle elementary
school in grand rapids
got the blisters to prove it on my hands
from stirring up a 40-pound batch of
sloppy joes
over the last two days so
yeah that's that's where i am right now
um
how i got there uh this this place this
college uh played a big part uh it
taught me a lot of great lessons that
have helped mold me into who i am uh
into the the the friend the father uh
the spouse the son brother whatever it
is in life uh i've been able to take
away great lessons from this school you
know in the classroom on the football
field
in the meal room just random
conversations
there's so much that you take in when
you're a part of hillsdale and hillsdale
college
one of the biggest things is uh is
perseverance and and preparedness i
think uh those are two important ps in
life
uh and with those you can you know you
can overcome anything uh because you
have a plan and then you can get through
that plan whatever happens
um my most kind of recent story with
that really over the last two years i
planned on being done with football
being retired but
i've always been kind of a fitness
junkie so i stayed in decent enough
shape and
got to the point where i got kind of
itchy towards the end of the season and
asked my agent if anybody needed help um
and you know so i was somewhat prepared
but
uh
the last go-round with the indianapolis
colts was a little different uh it was
the day after christmas it was a
previous o-line coach and i i got in the
car they needed help i went down there
since
christmas day was done and uh you know i
couldn't
go back on christmas plans with the
family as our first one back at home so
the gm actually reached out earlier in
december and i told him we'd have circle
back after christmas well day after
christmas i'm in the car going down to
indy
and they i was just told they needed
help on the o-line and you know i was
willing to pitch in and you know put my
hand in the pile whatever it took
uh but when i got down there they made
it clear that they really needed o-line
and they're like are you are you do you
think you can learn this and start the
next week
and i was like oh yeah sure yeah let's
let's do it why not um and so
i'm in the hotel there's a five-day
coveted protocol where you're just
sitting in a hotel doing covet testing
and uh you can't be with the team you
can do zoom meetings that kind of stuff
so my first day in the building was a
thursday and put it in some perspective
you play sunday
uh
and so i get there on thursday meet all
the players for the first time in person
actually have you know one legitimate
practice um have kind of a glorified
walkthrough on friday true walk through
on saturday and start the game on sunday
and
you know i kind of pinched myself all
the way through it because i was like
this is crazy this is absolute craziness
this is you know the highest level of
football and to the average person this
would just seem like utter just
unpreparedness like
there's no part of this that should be
happening
uh but luckily i was able to have a
background that taught me how to prepare
uh taught me how to take those five days
in the hotel and transition it into
being able to play on sunday and lean on
on the lessons that i've learned the the
ten years prior to that and was able to
step out there and play in a game uh
that that sunday and then play in the
next week uh versus the bills in a
playoff game so just kind of a quick
synopsis on you know some of the things
that this college has taught me and then
uh the perseverance side uh is just not
quitting not giving up like i uh you
know said in that video and it's hard
to watch that and not get emotional with
it because that was tough um
to get you know to to have to relearn
something completely
um just because someone said that's what
you're doing now
i really honestly did want to quit i
wanted to be done uh and again that's
where i'm i'm really grateful for uh my
family my friends you know just the
support around me uh to get through that
and to just reinforce that that i could
do it you just got to give it time have
a plan lean on that preparedness and uh
and just flex those perseverance muscles
and
you know it's like anything they build
up over time so
anyone here
you know if there's one takeaway from
tonight just be prepared have a plan and
persevere through that plan and uh this
this school definitely taught me how to
do that so thank you guys
can't forget my award and mr lantis
could you make sure that uh next time uh
you make sure the school lunch lady is
uh
on the official transcript of
that's a proud moment in light you know
not too many lunch ladies can get up
here and accept this award
[Applause]
our next honoree this evening is joy
pullman
who happens to be from the stellar class
of 2009
joy manages to artfully balance a career
as managing editor of the federalist a
web magazine on politics policy and
culture with being a wife and mother of
six children
joy also works as a research fellow on
education policy for the heartland
institute
as the former managing editor of school
reform news joy interviewed and produced
podcasts with many of the leading
figures in school reform
she was also assistant editor for the
american magazine at the american
enterprise institute joy is the
2013-14 recipient of robert novak
journalism fellowship
for in-depth reporting on common core
national education standards
joy's accomplished journalism has been
published accomplished journalism has
been published by the new york times
washington examiner the weekly standard
washington times milwaukee journal
senator
salt lake tribune
national review online real clear policy
and various other u.s newspapers and
outlets
joy has written a series of research and
commentary reports on the parent tiger a
new school reform idea sweeping the
country and is co-author with joseph l
bast the parent trigger justification
and design guidelines heartland
institute 2012.
joy has taught middle and high school
students history literature and debate
and is authored high school public
speaking curriculum she has traveled
nationwide to speak at prominent venues
including cpac the national right to
life convention and statewide education
conferences
she has been guests on numerous talk
shows including fox and friends the john
stossel show and wall street journal's
opinion journal
joy graduated from hillsdale with an
english major and journalism
concentration
she lives in indiana with her husband
nathaniel also a 2009 hillsdale graduate
and their six children
please give your attention to the screen
to meet our distinguished alumni honoree
joy pullman
my name is greg coleman i am a mother
with six kids
and i'm the executive editor at the
federalist
i get up at 5 30 i may have 6 000 words
to edit between 6 and 8 a.m may have 50
emails to answer as well then i head to
the kitchen to see what state it's in
with all of my children hanging from the
chandeliers we don't have chandeliers 1
32 o'clock is nap time and then i'm
working
i get a lot from young women you know
how do you do it
i say
try not to if you can help
[Music]
looking at all the college options that
i had why was i going to college in the
first place i was going to college to be
educated to take the talents that i had
and make the most of it
i had a gut feeling that at hillsdale is
where i would get the best education you
know the only thing i wish that would
have been better about my hillsdale
experience was me
well you know you're 18 years old and
stupid
i was an english major and i knew that
from the beginning i loved to write
what i loved really about reporting in
college was being a conduit for other
people's stories how do you get people
interested how do you make sure it's
organized clearly all of those kind of
bits about the craft after hillsdale i
did huge amounts of on-the-ground
reporting i was one of the earliest
people to even pay any attention to this
thing called common core
it came to me from grass roots from a
mom she called me one day and said
why aren't there any reporters covering
this thing called common core i think
this was 2012 or 2013. it was before
this became a huge grassroots issue
she was saying you know my local school
district is talking about it and i tried
to go to a public meeting about and they
wouldn't let me in i was
instantly
on her behalf wondering okay this is
weird this shouldn't happen government
101 the people are allowed to go to
public meetings
i also tried to get into that meeting
they wouldn't talk to me about it or let
me know anything about it i just
published a story about the fact that
none of you know they weren't letting
anyone do that information and i got
deluged with emails from people saying
we heard about this too what is this
thing
i happen to be someone just doing basic
journalism when no other outlets were
doing basic journalism on this thing
that really aimed to completely overhaul
and nationalize american education
because of that i became you know he got
a huge following huge amount of
readership and that turned into a book
[Music]
then it started getting huge media
attention and became a thing that even
eventually donald trump started talking
about
reporting on common core played into our
decision to start a school
people need to be more and better
educated the education is the formation
of a human soul and the kind of souls
that you have in your country determine
whether it can be self-governing and i
want my children to be self-governing
and i want their neighbors to be
self-governing
so we started redeemer classical school
in 2016. and it was one room school
house
you know then now we're a four-room
schoolhouse my husband is the headmaster
of the school
and i'm the executive editor at the
federalist
when you have a heart commitment to the
things that are good for me it's really
got me through a lot i mean
i know doing all the things that i do
has is has been basically a battle the
whole time so
you don't have the heart to fight you
know without someone having shown you
what's worth fighting for
and so that's what i really got from my
uh the classes at hillsdale taught me
what to love right rather than fighting
in bitterness
dr sundell was one of my freshman
english professors and then i took him
of course a bunch of other times the
things that he would talk about in class
were just so touching um that that i
would sit in the back of his class and
cry you know as quietly as i could i
think of hillsdale is kind of like the
shining city on a hill it's this
beautiful place that is so unlike so
almost everywhere else that we have in
the world of course you know it's not a
perfect place but it has so many
excellencies all together in one place
and people have worked over centuries
and they sacrificed to make that
possible so you can go there and get
refreshed you can go there and have hope
you know our country is in really
dangerous times through my work you see
some of that grave danger in hillsdale
is for me what gives me so often the
courage to get out there and keep taking
swings
right when i graduated i really wish i
could go back and do it all over again
[Applause]
joy on behalf of alumni association of
hillsdale college it's my great honor to
present you with the distinguished
alumna award in journalism
congratulations
[Applause]
well hillsdale made me a writer and my
husband a teacher so they are not giving
me this award for all the big checks
that we write them
all the big checks that we have we put
into the school pretty much um
but there as i was thinking about
talking to you all tonight i did think
about some checks that really mattered a
lot to me that have come to hillsdale
they came by the hand of my father who
wrote his portion of that six percent
for my college tuition
he is unable to be here tonight but i
know that he's watching so i wanted to
recognize
the contributions that my father made
and made it possible for me to go to
hillsdale in first place now i know what
my father did to earn that tuition money
i'm the daughter of a farmer
so when i was a child i would see him
come home you know sometimes i would
hear from my mother he'd come home at
midnight gone back out 3 a.m to check on
the irrigation pumps
and you know i would see him sometimes
come back from what they call the grain
bins covered in white dust smelling
really really awful
and
when i came to school here
and
i knew that what my father had done to
make it possible for me to be here and
that is why i didn't spend a lot of time
partying
so although
perhaps those checks were small in the
scheme of things they matter a lot to me
and i want to thank all of you for your
six percent or maybe more that you have
given to make it possible
and i want to say especially thanks dad
for what you did because without you
having done that i wouldn't be here
right now so this is really for you dad
thanks
[Applause]
i also wanted to recognize um
people who are as important to me as
family so another one of the most
glorious things about my hillsdale
experience was the people was the
friendships that we made here on campus
and um
you know even though you heard about my
bio and it sounds probably really great
and you know people kind of sauced those
up to make them look better right
but you know so i've
you know flown to new york city to go on
fox news but you know what really
is much much more important than any of
the things on my bio is seeing the faces
that are right here at this table
i'm looking at each one of these people
who most of whom we went to college same
class
well maybe i won't i was about to say
personal things about all of you so i'll
you know who you are
people at this table
have written checks for our school to
start even if they it wasn't possible
for their kids to go to the school
people at you know at this table have
shown up when i was flat on my back sick
picked up my children for me
people that
they have
they got an email from me saying i'm
going to get this free award can't
believe it we want to come have some
free wine
just kidding
we're not that low anymore we just used
to be in college
um so i mean um
there's nothing that's more important
than
the people at those table at that table
and i would rather have their honor and
their presence and their esteem
um
far more than pretty much anything else
so that's
who i'm here for tonight and i thank you
all for coming
and thank you to dr aaron and for the
college for this honor i don't know that
i deserve it but i'll do my best um to
be worth
the dessert to to use your name well
so thank you all
thank you joy
receiving our third distinguished
alumnus award this evening is howard
smith class of 1968.
howard was born in dayton ohio he earned
a bachelor of arts in history with a
minor in business from hillsdale he was
involved in a number of campus
activities including deltata delta
fraternity and was a member of both the
football and track teams
during his freshman year howard met
pamela norris class of 68 they married
in 1971.
pamela passed away in 2013 after 42
years of marriage
after graduation smith spent the next
four years serving his country in the
united states coast guard in 1973 he
went to work for pam's family business
the wilson
bohannon lock company howard spent the
first 22 years of his 48-year career at
wilsonville bohannon in the accounting
department in 1995 he became president
and ceo
during this time he earned an mba from
ashland university
the company is proud to be a hundred
percent american-made manufacturer of
brass padlocks and locking devices that
can be found all over the world
howard and pam's two daughters sarah
smith russell 08 and trish smith as well
as his son-in-law aaron rassel are the
seventh generation to work for the
company
making a difference in his local
community of marion ohio has always been
a high priority for howard he has served
on numerous boards including the
convention and visitors bureau
the red cross and the ymca he's the past
president of the marion rotary club
marion can do development board and the
ymca endowment board he currently serves
on the marion can do and marion general
hospital boards he's a member of the
manufacturer's council the industrial
club and rotary
smith and the wilson bohannon lock
company have been honored in recent
years in 2018 he was inducted into the
lock collectors hall of fame and in 2019
received a lifetime achievement award
from the conway family business center
in columbus ohio
in 2020 the wilson bohannon lock company
was chosen to represent ohio at the
fourth annual made in america product
showcase at the white house with
president trump
please give your attention to the screen
to our distinguished alumnus honoree
howard smith
[Applause]
first you listen
and you learn and you watch and you wait
your opportunity
and then you when you're given
opportunity you do the best you possibly
can with an opportunity it's easy to be
successful when all the times are good
that's when the times are not good and
how do you bridge that to when the times
start getting good again and i believe
you know if you apply yourself the
american dream is possible for anybody
today
[Music]
my name is howard smith i'm president of
the wilson bahamas lock company marion
ohio my wife's grandfather mr wilson by
hannah and toy
came through here on a troop train
stopped at a canteen stop
and remember the friendliness of the
people in marion so here is where we
came
in 1926 and here's where we are today
almost 100 years later with about 70
employees making padlocks that are used
all over the world
we're seven generation family business
and very proud to be hundreds on
american-made i went to high school
in dayton ohio and about 95 of my high
school class goes on to college so my
parents are going crazy you know at the
end of the whole situation all my
friends are enrolled somewhere you know
where's my son gonna go what's you know
and he'll still with the conservative
values and the student guide did this
rugged belt was beautiful and they just
said this is where we want you to go
i met my wife my third week at school
her great great grandfather started the
company in brooklyn new york in 1860
with his son todd and shed behind their
house so she didn't want to be
in the business she wanted to be part of
the business
and so she was on the board of directors
you know she was the guidance counselor
marine catholic for over 30 years
she loved her school she loved her
community she loved this company and
people
just loved pam she was kind loving
um just a big heart you know it's always
a place for any student to come to pam
and talk to him to her about any
situation and her passion for wilson by
hannah comey was powerful and infectious
said all everybody knew how much she
loved this place and she built that
legacy with my two daughters and sadly
she was she passed away you know for 42
years of marriage what better way could
she carry on her memory and been
something she had so much pride in you
know in this company
we make over 5 000 bucks a day we're
most always in job shops all made to
order this specification of our
customers there's no lock manufacturer
like us in america today they can do the
things we can do with the tolerance we
can do so i'm proud of that proud that
we're made in this country proud that
you know the symbol of like hill still
talks about you know the conservative
values
and their christian attitude that's why
we're around our business with the
christian attitude and in the belief in
the constitution
hillsdale taught me to be a good
corporate citizen i want to give back i
want a place where my daughters can
raise their family i want a place where
my you know my employees can feel good
about themselves when you hire people
when you bring people from other parts
of the country
are you going to bring them to some
place they don't want to live
[Music]
hill still just is that side post that
that guide post hanging you know that
telling his health is the best way to do
things i think i said before you know
the american dream is alive and well in
this country and i just want to be an
example we're not just a business we're
a human business with human people who
care with respect to dignity you know of
each other and building a culture that's
you know it's powerful people walk
through our factories say gee whiz i
mean
everybody has a good attitude they like
what they do they're proud of this
company
it's creating a culprit culture
that
allows people to grow and be something
and be part of that of a larger part of
something than just themselves it's not
just me it's it's all the people that
surround me all the people that have
made this a great company you know like
i couldn't do without all people and so
i do when i go to the factory every
single day i thank our employees thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
howard on behalf of the alumni
association of hillsdale college it's my
great honor to present you with the
distinguished alumnus award for
outstanding professional achievement in
management congratulations
i want to thank hillsdale college and
everyone who was involved in this award
ceremony tonight
especially dr arne
for this evening and i made it possible
i want to thank my family and friends
who are here tonight
i want to thank penny
and steve
miller from columbus penny is a member
of the pi beta 5 sorority
and to jerry and rocco
from dayton
for all her love and support
my daughter sarah
who was a student here and a member of
kappa kappa gangnam authority and her
husband aaron
who both work for our family business
and to doug zimmerman
from boise idaho
it was a classmate an outstanding
cross-country runner
and a member of the track team
and lastly i want to bet shafer
from dayton
beth and my wife pam were sorority
sisters akaya make a sorority
and alan and i have been lifelong
friends
allen was a 1960 class president and
president our fraternity de la tall
delta
i look back on my life and i ask myself
what the hillsdale college mean to me as
a student in the 60s
i wanted to make my parents proud of me
i wanted to enjoy the experience i
wanted to participate in as many things
as they possibly could many activities i
was a history major and a business minor
student guide for four years here
played football and track and enjoy i
had a chance to throw the javelin
something i couldn't do obviously in
high school
and a member of the delta dental
fraternity and the leadership workshop
and the union policy board
in 1920
our company
was selected to be the fourth annual
made in america product showcase service
in the state of ohio
i thought how could any award ever
receive any greater than this until i
got a call about several months ago
and i was asked and told that i was
going to be recipient of this award
i said this is the most outstanding
thing that i've ever because i believe
so much in hillsdale college and what it
means today
hill still gave me a foundation for
being a successful business person
after graduating from college i spent
the next four years in the u.s coast
guard
and i started i was married in 1971 and
1973 i started working for the wilson
manhattan lock company first as an
accountant and that is his president
wilson bohannon looks a lot different
today than it did back when i started
there in 1973 almost 50 years ago
back then where all we did was that we
assembled today we're totally
integrating making all of our
manufacture parts in one location
the two most powerful words i believe in
business today
is communication and love
i keep every one of our officers and our
staff included in our plans and our
visions are leading the company
showing continuous love and respect
for all of our associates is essential
the top five officers of wilson and
company have over 180 years experience
in the lock industry in our company
transitioning from the sixth generation
to the seventh generation my two
daughters and my son-in-law
i hope someday that my grandchildren or
the eighth generation will be continuing
on our legacy
thank you hillsdale college for
providing me with these tools i needed
to lead a seven generation
family business that is proud to be a
hundred percent american-made
god bless our country
god bless foster college
as a defender of our constitution
and thank you for this great honor you
bestowed upon me tonight
[Applause]
thank you howard
receiving our fourth distinguished award
this evening is ron gladnick class of
1983.
ron is the head football coach at torrey
pines high school in san diego
california and former ceo of apical
industries which manufactures helicopter
flotation systems
pretty amazing
a defensive lineman for the chargers ron
played on the 1980 and 1982 gliac
championship teams and was named
all-american he was inducted into the
hillsdale college athletic hall of fame
in 2008.
ron coached defensive line for the
chargers and worked in the college's
advancement office before moving to san
diego in 1991.
there he established apical industries
which grew to more than 500 employees in
seven facilities producing ninety
percent of the market share of
helicopter flotation systems
in 2007 dart helicopter services
acquired the business
and ron sold his interest in the company
in 2011 but continues to work as a
partner in two aviation parts companies
since 2014 ron has served as head
football coach at torrey pines high
school
he works tirelessly with young men
turning a failing program into a
championship team
in 2021 ron led a successful grassroots
campaigns to resume youth sports
competition in california which had been
suspended due to covet 19.
ron lives in california beach community
just north of san diego with his wife
joanna he has two daughters karina and
kaylia
and at this point i'd like you to turn
your attention to the screen to meet ron
you know what the first thing we teach
our ninth graders
has nothing to do with football
all right hey heads up
summer's over
you know it's time to go to work has
everything to do with how to shake a
man's hand and have a lookie in the eye
and that's where we start
it has everything to do with building
great young men
and i believe if you do that the
football will take care of itself
my name is ron gladnick and i'm the head
football coach at torrey pines high
school
at hillsdale as a freshman i had the
benefit of
probably playing on one of the worst
football teams in the history of
hillsdale college we were three and
eight
you know when coach dye and coach lowry
came to hillsdale my sophomore year we
spent the next three months at six
o'clock in the morning
where they had turned the heat up in the
field house felt like 110
you know the most brutal workouts
quite frankly to get guys who aren't
committed to leave which a bunch of them
did and then over the next
three years
i was a part of that transition from
being
you know a very bad football team
to being one of the best division two
football teams in the country
i was a business major and an english
minor
i love a liberal arts education for that
reason it creates well-rounded people
and like i tell everybody the most
valuable thing about hillsdale college
is you learn how to learn
and as a result of that i've always felt
i don't care what environment you put me
in i am going to learn
and then i'm going to become competent
and then i'm going to compete
my whole
adult life i've been you know a
self-employed entrepreneur i've built
small companies into medium sized
companies
and that entails being everything from
the ceo to the janitor and i would say
that very much
sums up my business experience my
football experience and my life
experience
2006
i brought everybody in the conference
room and said look you guys are
brilliant i hired all of you you're
smarter than me i'm gonna go coach high
school football
you guys run the company and they did a
great job i always tell everybody i
worked hard my whole life to getting
back to doing what i loved the most
when i first started coaching it was
like hurting cats if you're if you want
to be competitive
in
you know
high level california football
that it's it's 12 months of the year now
you know we we end our season we're in
the weight room the following monday
and a parent stood up and said why are
you doing this i said because it's hard
because boys need hard
because life is hard
my first season we were six and four in
18 we were
12-1
we've won the toughest league in the
county three times
the expectations are high
in march 2020 before our spring break
we were told school would be closed for
two weeks
it ended up being for over a year
i got more phone calls from kids in
trouble
from march of 2020 to
march of 2021
in all of my previous 14 years combined
we were right there
our kids after a lift i was looking at
the kids
and i don't even know what came over me
but i looked at the kids i say look
i'm probably gonna crash and burn
but i promise you
i'm gonna do everything i can
as your head coach to get sports back
and that's how it
started local coaches parents and
athletes say enough is enough it's time
for change it's time to play sports
again and now they're holding an event
to get this state to pay attention head
football coach at torrey pines high
school ron gladden ron gladnick ron
gladnick coach thank you for once again
joining us we started we we formed six
seal teams of parent volunteers who had
different jobs
i was in charge of seal team six
which was engaging our politicians we
started an app we got 1600 head high
school football coaches in california in
the app and 7 000 assistant coaches
so 11 days after i started it was 4 30
in the afternoon my cell phone rang and
it was gavin newsom
and i talked
for 45 minutes and what i left him with
was this
i said governor we are not political we
do not want to be political we want to
do the right thing for kids
he wanted sports back
but the
mosh pit of special interests that you
had to work through to get it back
from that day took five weeks until we
finally got it
done
and as a result not only did we get high
school football back we got all high
school sports back
all seasons were played from march to
june
youth sports were returned
it was incredible
three million 3.3 million kids
got to play
what could be better than that
at the end of the day our our whole
program here has nothing to do with
football it has everything to do with
building great young men
and i believe if you do that the
football will take care of itself
and i learned that from dick lowry this
is stuff i learned from my college head
coach my defensive coordinator
so i you know for me it all started
there
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful
thank you so much
ron on behalf of the hillsdale college
alumni association we present you with
the distinguished award for outstanding
achievement
and
i'm going to have to look directly at
you
very very good um
i've forgotten the category i lost my
page no worries
but congratulations
[Applause]
i've limited my comments to two hours
and 27 minutes so
um
i've never been one to reflect on a
birthday
um to me you know you're
you're the age you feel and
i've always tried to approach life
feeling young and vibrant and
enthusiastic every single day but on
september 12th i turn 60
and it's the first time i've ever paused
in my life and
really reflected on
how you get to a certain place in time
and and what was fascinating about
taking some time to do that is
your whole life is determined by
really at the end of the day a few
chance interactions that change the
course of your life
and i was a young kid back east
getting ready to sign with syracuse
university for football who was not very
good
and
john cervini entered my life
came to recruit me
[Music]
my parents are very conservative
so john i will never forget this i've
told this story 100 times he was a much
bigger guy back then
came into my living room and sat with my
mother and father and he crossed his leg
and he balanced a coffee cup on a little
tiny plate on his thigh
and talked to my parents for a long like
i kept looking at the cup going it's a
matter of time
but he never he the guy never flinched
and
i forget what day of the week it was but
john came i talked to my parents i went
to bed i woke up the next day my mom and
dad said you're going to hillsdale
college
so that that was my choice
um
and then i and then i got here and
you know for a kid back east coming to
the midwest for the first time it was it
was
a lot of culture shock um
and it was really different and we were
a terrible football team i mean really
bad i mean so bad
and
there are people
you know so i always look back and john
got me to hillsdale college
and hillsdale college changed the course
of my whole life
and then
john wilson my advisor is john here
stand up john
[Applause]
my first two years here john wilson kept
me in school
kept me
was not only a mentor and my advisor but
was a friend
a friend who cared about you personally
you know well beyond the scope of his
job as a professor and an advisor and
you know there were some bumpy moments
in that first two years and john was
always a calming
influence and always was
the guy hey it's going to be okay and
we'll move on to the next thing and
so john you changed the course of my
life by being a good friend
and being a great history professor
and i appreciate you very
much um
my mom and dad are too frail to travel
but they're watching tonight along with
my family and i want to thank them all
i want to thank my mom and dad for
raising us right my brother and sister
and i
and i look at our families now and we
spent a lot of time together and
none of that would have happened without
them so they changed the course of my
life
one of the beautiful things about
hillsdale for me is
that ability to be put in any
environment and thrive
and i i don't know that
people value that skill set enough
anymore
and
but it's the most important thing this
college does
because it i i look at jared i look at
you i look at all the people that have
spoken here tonight and
i i get the sense you can be put in any
environment in and succeed now jared i'm
older than you you know so at my bones
creak and stuff so i did want to put my
head on your body for a year and your
head on my body so you can get a preview
of what the future holds
it's a gift
um
i'd like to thank jeff lannis because
jeff
does an amazing job of keeping guys like
me who are far away connected to the
college
and his impact on
my tie to hillsdale college you know has
been very very dramatic
um at the end of the day
coach larry and coach dye you know
the professors and the courses and all
the things that we do here
again gave me the gift to learn
it was the
organizational
efficiency
that dick lowry and
dave dye taught me
that shaped my business career
because it was hard
they treated people with dignity and
respect
but then they empowered us to be
successful
and
that's the cornerstone of every single
business i've ever run
treat people right
you know we had 500 employees no one
ever punched a clock in the company ever
you had to go to a baseball game for
your kid go to a baseball game
you needed to be an adult and make
decisions about your time go ahead just
get your work done
and i was always so proud
i would drive by the facility at 11
o'clock at night and there'd be 20
lights on in the building because people
did the right thing when given the
choice to do the right thing
and my experience with a football team
or a company
a group of adults or a group of
teenagers is if if you treat them right
and you love them
and you look out for their best
interests and they know you do
the lion's share of people will do the
right thing every single time
and
if i could leave you with one thought it
would be this
be humble
work hard
do the best you can
and at the end of the day when your work
is done hopefully we'll leave the earth
in a better place than we found it
and if you do that
like me
because of hillsdale college you too
will have a beautiful life
i thank you so much this is such a
humbling experience for me
i love being back here
fills my soul with all the good stuff
thank you dr arnon and doctor and thank
you for continuously raising the
academic standards so that when i'm out
in the world and i say i went to
hillsong college well that's just like
the ivy league and i go yes
yes it is
so thank you sir
god bless thank you very much
i forgot to thank three people
but coming up here gives me a chance to
say that two things one is
i'm glad joy got the award because
otherwise all the entire field would
have been a much better football player
than i ever was
also the kids don't actually walk around
in slow motion on the college campus
walking through molasses who i forgot to
to thank or marianne rotell and carrie
cummins who've been just tremendous in
this job and the alumni board is
growing all the time and it's a blessing
to the college and i'm grateful
and of course colleen is excellent at
the job
and i don't know if neil cole is going
to be any good but we have her fingers
crossed
thank you all for being here
[Applause]
thank you dr earn
such inspiring stories tonight it truly
was an honor to be among these awardees
and this concludes the presentation of
our awards
congratulations to all of you and at
this time i'd like to ask colleen to
come to the podium for a few closing
remarks
thank you
well we have a party planned afterward
and i know you're all i hope you're all
anxious to get to it i hope it becomes a
fun night not that it is not ready but
we have the hillcats faculty jazz band
who are going to who played earlier for
us they're going to continue on for a
couple hours and we have uh quite a few
alumni who are out
in enjoying a reception who are going to
join and merge with us for a decade's
party so i hope you'll stay for that
um
i have a few more housekeeping
announcements before we adjourn
um
we
i want to run through a little bit of
what's going on tomorrow just as a
reminder but we have the it's the
pancakes pancake brunch outside of the
chapel tomorrow from 9 to 11 in front of
christ chapter chapel sorry the alumni
choir will be practicing with the music
program in the chapel and we'll have a
brief performance at noon in christ
chapel the alumni tailgate will be from
noon to four over by the sports complex
and will feature food of course beer and
music from alumna nicole cory's band
arctic clam the football game begins at
four and the first 100 people to check
in at the alumni tent will receive a
discounted ticket
following the game we'll be hosting a
fifth quarter reception in the
president's suite which is inside the
sports complex where we'll be able to
watch some of the students mock rock
dances if you're into that kind of thing
i want to thank bon appetit and the
searle center team for all their good
work as well as the alumni office team
for their effort putting together this
weekend i want to particularly thank
particularly thank ashley salos who is
the lead planner for all of our
homecoming festivities she's worked
tirelessly thank you ashley
i'd like to thank dr arn and john
cervini for supporting our alumni
outreach ventures in the alumni office
our alumni are very important part of
the hillsdale family and spending time
together we'll continue to build that
relationship
so i want you to mark your calendars for
may 19-22 where we'll host our second
annual white and blue weekend and it's a
weekend just for alumni if you haven't
heard of it we had our first white and
blue weekend this last may it was a
blast there's something for everyone
including your kids if you have them and
lots of room on campus for alumni to
take over and enjoy campus and academic
life once again so please
consider joining us for that this year
if you didn't last here
and also if you did come back
it's been such a joy to welcome you all
back home
i'm always very inspired by this evening
it's my favorite night of the year and
it's really fun to spotlight and elevate
our alumni they're just fantastic
ambassadors of what hillsdale does here
so very proud to do that as you know
there's no place like hillsdale and we
need the college now more than ever
thank you so much and enjoy the rest of
your evening
[Applause]
bye